so a couple of days ago a restaurant
owner in los angeles named angela
marsden
recorded a video with her honest and raw
emotional understandably emotional
reaction to her city shutdown order
she like so many restaurant owners in
the area and elsewhere in the country
had the rug pulled out from under them
when you know she spent lots of time and
money setting up an outdoor dining area
only to be told that outdoor dining
would be banned there's of course
no coherent reason to ban outdoor dining
well there is no good and coherent
reason
the actual reason is that politicians
want to flex their muscles grab more
power
tighten their control over the
population that's plenty coherent
i mean it makes sense but it isn't very
good at least it's not morally ethically
or constitutionally good
in any case angela marsden's video has
gone viral for good reason
and if you haven't heard or seen it
we'll play a little bit of it here
uh here it is i'm losing everything
everything i own is being taken away
from me and they set up a movie company
right next to my outdoor patio which is
right over here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
look at this tell me
that this is dangerous but
right next to me is a slap in my face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away this is dangerous
mayor garcetti and gavin newsom is
responsible
for every single person that doesn't
have unemployment
that does not have a job and all the
businesses that are going under
and we need your help we need somebody
to do something about this
what you're hearing there by the way
that is uh righteous indignation that is
real
righteous indignation okay that's that's
that's what righteous indignation sounds
like doesn't sound like you know
a college student claiming that they're
being persecuted because they have to
pay back their loans so this is someone
who's losing everything while hollywood
studios are setting up their tents now
if you're wondering
a report in the independent says that
the setup was for
caterers for the film crew of the nbc
show good girls
and this is really neither here nor
there i suppose but wikipedia tells me
that the series quote
follows three suburban michigan mothers
two of whom are sisters
who are having a hard time trying to
make ends meet they're tired of having
everything taken away from them so they
decide to pull off an
unlikely heist by robbing a supermarket
only to discover that they're in for
more than they bargained
i just wanted to read that to you
because the fact that exceptions are
being made for this
vapid ridiculous television show only
highlights the arbitrary cruelty of all
this
but obviously if those tents were for
the crew of a good show what few exist
it still wouldn't be any less outrageous
either way
hollywood productions are now considered
essential
essential to whom is the question they
may indeed be essential to the people
working on them but in that sense
all jobs are essential and that's been
my point all along all jobs are
essential because
they all have at least one person who
depends on them for survival
but are these productions essential in
any other sench sense
are they essential in a deeper sense
than say a restaurant or a bar is
essential
no in fact i'd say that your local
restaurant
where the community comes to gather
together and share a meal
is far more important to that community
than
good girls on nbc good girls on nbc
could disappear from the face of the
earth
and nobody except the people working on
it would even notice or care i didn't
even know the show existed until right
now
even the fans of the show would
immediately replace it with some other
show
not missing a beat or stopping to mourn
but when a favorite local business goes
under as
many of them are right now you feel that
loss if you're in the community it's a
sad day even 20 years later you may be
driving by the place
where the business used to be and you'll
turn to the person in the car with you
and you'll say i remember
i remember there used to be a bar there
called so and so and man i used to love
that place etc etc
20 years from now nobody's going to be
talking about good girls on nbc or
remembering it fondly
this all simply highlights the injustice
that we've been witnessing
and it's one of the great injustices
ever perpetrated by the american
government on its citizens
that is not hyperbole the government is
arbitrarily wiping out thousands of
businesses
all at once while allowing the more
powerful companies and
industries to keep running and even to
more than that
increase their profits and all the while
the people having their lives destroyed
have to endure the lectures and sneering
from the people whose lives have only
improved if anything during the
lockdowns for example
pete davidson a man who is about as
witty and charismatic as a dead tortoise
but who still pulls a paycheck as a
professional comedian somehow
was on snl this weekend to mock the
lockdown protesters as nothing but a
bunch of babies
listen i take it that you found these
protests frustrating
yeah man they're making us look like
babies you know you know it's bad when
even people in boston are like
ah drink it home your quiz
and do you think that people should stay
at home until the pandemic gets better
yeah everyone wants to go have fun but
there's plenty of stuff you could do at
home
like use your official pete davidson
vibrated
yeah great great jokes there um that's
professional that's professional comedy
by the way
you know why people don't want to eat
drink outside because uh it's it's a
high of 40 degrees today in new york
that's why that's why restaurants are
going to lose their business if they
have to send their people outside people
aren't going to sit and eat and drink at
40 degree temperatures
but anyway he says baby yeah baby says
says the 27 year old man who still looks
acts and sounds like a seventh grader in
after school detention
a man who more importantly has a job is
making money
has not been financially devastated by
the lockdowns
it's funny how the people who support
the lockdowns and sneer at those who
protest
and resist the lockdowns are almost
always also people who still have jobs
you notice this in the media too all the
time here's a segment that aired on cnn
a couple days ago
listen to this cnn talking head speaking
from his studio at his job
as he explains why those who are asked
to give up their jobs
shouldn't complain that much listen
what's happening in los angeles i just
want to make clear
it's a huge sacrifice he's asking for
but it's not
everything retail stores are still open
there's a lot of offices still open
movie television production which drives
the economy out there
it's still happening he's just asking
people to make sensible
decisions and when you look around the
world you see it works
you see what's happened in these
european countries where they've
instituted measures
like this for short periods of time and
it breaks the rise it just does israel's
done it like three times
you know they keep having to do it but
the country is willing
to do it by and large and when they do
it it it
just stops that incredibly fast rising
cases and hospitalizations
it works i mean it works so much they've
done it three times that's how much it
works
they work so much they just keep doing
it
yes it's uh it well it's a big sacrifice
he says but but uh but come on
you know we can do it and besides
walmart's still open that should be
solace to you if you lost your job it's
not the end of the world what's the
problem
it's not everything he says you're not
asked being asked to give up
everything of course he's being asked to
give up
nothing so the guy who's giving up
nothing wants you to know that however
however much you're giving up is not
really
that much in the grand scheme of things
this is why it pains me so much that the
people who push for lockdowns
also get to pretend that they're the
compassionate and selfless ones
the truth is whether lockdown shutdowns
and masking are the right or wrong
approach and i think they're wrong
obviously but
right or wrong if you're pushing for
them
you are almost certainly pushing for
them because you're scared
and you want to feel safe you know you
want
other people to do something to submit
to something to give up something to
give up everything
potentially for your sake to protect you
never is this more clear than when
four-year-olds are required to wear
masks to walk through a store or get on
an airplane
that isn't to protect them they're not
at any significant risk from covid
they also aren't at any significant risk
to spread coven yet we want them muzzled
we the adults so that we feel safer
around them
and that guy on cnn or pete davidson
they want the bars to
stay shut and business has to close down
so that they can be safe
they are asking other people to make a
sacrifice
for them call that whatever you want to
call it but don't call it compassion
don't call it courage don't call it
selflessness
is exactly the opposite it is cowardice
and fear and that's what we should call
it
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated